[Music]
so Yahoo Sports was putting together a
happy birthday video for hashtag Tommy
and Sam Donald the second year Jets
quarterback who is 22 to Brady's 42
declined to participate let's just sit
man knowing what I've got to do I'm
gonna get every competitive edge I can
because he's gonna do the same thing
he's the ultimate competitor he's
exactly where I want to be when I'm his
age to chase that I can't be giving him
anything
dude all you're doing is saying happy
birthday for crying out loud it's not
like you're buying him a car just say
happy birthday learn how to be fake you
can hate him privately just say happy
birthday and be done with it anyway
that gave us the inspiration shirin for
today's draft very simple because look
the Patriots are still the class of the
AFC they prove it every year they've
been to the AFC championship game every
season since 2011 for crying out loud so
which team is the biggest threat to the
Patriots and Tom Brady in the AFC
obviously there's gonna be six teams
that we pick and since you have filled
in and in the pinch again you get to go
first no coin toss I don't win them
anyway so you get the first pick well
I'm throwing you a huge curveball here
because when I got it from stats it
didn't say which team it says what is
the biggest threat to the this is good
threat the the biggest threat should be
obvious an injury to Tom Brady is the
biggest threat to the Patriots not going
back to the Super Bowl to represent the
AFC even then they're gonna be
contenders because we saw it when he got
hurt in that Chiefs game in the first
game of 2008 and they still went 11 and
5 and they didn't make the playoffs I
understand still had a winning record
with Matt Cassel of all people so this
is a team that can win even when Tom
Brady's not there but I don't think they
can win a Super Bowl of Tom Brady's not
there well well done well done I'll give
you that one and I want the record to be
clear that if Tom Brady gets injured
Shareen is the one who applied the jinx
not me do not blame me Patriots fans
she's the one that has
identified the primary threat to Tom
Brady and New England Patriots I like
the creativity
I guess my pick should be another
suspension for Tom Brady although I
don't think the NFL is in the business
of suspending great players now they
realize the impact of not having great
players on ratings which then impacts
the bottom line so I'll take the the
most obvious team that they need to be
concerned about the team that almost
beat them in the AFC Championship game
and the team this is gonna be coming at
them harder than ever the Kansas City
Chiefs who have beefed up their defense
and their defense didn't have to be much
better for them to be better than the
Patriots and I think they've done enough
defensively that the Chiefs are even
though I'm not ready to say the Chiefs
can but I think they are a threat and
the biggest threat other than injury to
Tom Brady to the Patriots in the AFC
such a predictable answer Mike I knew
you would go there but it is the right
choice but you know what I said
yesterday and so I have to stick to that
and I know it's going to be old takes
exposed if they don't come back and even
make the playoffs but I've got to go
with the Colts right because I said it
yesterday I am putting an asterisk on
this with Andrew Luck for 16 games he's
got to be there if Andrew Luck's not
there all bets are off I'm not taking
the Colts but if Android Luck's there I
eat the Colts are terrific and I like
what they're building I think they're
gonna be good for a long time but I
think they're gonna be really good this
year if Andrew Luck plays yeah and and I
don't disagree with that because of what
they built last year and how well they
exceeded their expectations because they
have that great offensive line they've
drafted very well with Chris Ballard and
Frank Reich even though he wasn't on the
radar screen before they had the wink
nod agreement with Josh McDaniels he
emerged as the clear candidate after
McDaniels backed out and Frank Reich
just feels like the guy who should have
been the first choice all along so it's
worked out well for the Colts and I
agree with you if Andrew Luck's healthy
they will be a serious threat I'm gonna
go with another predictable one assuring
you kind of sandbagged me on both of
these until round three with the injury
to Tom Brady and the Colts I'll take the
other obvious one it's a Pittsburgh
Steelers they are motivated they are
upset they are keenly aware of the fact
that the Patriots
caught them with six all-time Super Bowl
championships and they roll into
Foxborough week one and and I think that
Mike Tomlin and company know no matter
how they got there and even though it's
kind of self inflicted with the way they
mishandled Antonio Brown and Le'Veon
Bell they I think have pulled together
tightly and Ben Roethlisberger has a
chip on his shoulder bigger than ever he
got a lot of guys in that locker room
they're upset about what happened last
year and they're coming together and
doing everything they need to do
checking every box necessary to get
themselves in position to win and I
think this year and remember last year
the Steelers did beat the Patriots in
the regular season which you know
typically when those two teams get
together the Patriots find a way to make
it happen for them
I think the Steelers if they encounter
them in the postseason this year this
could be the year that the Steelers find
a way to take down the Patriots there's
no question the Steelers are motivated
they have the quarterback and they have
the coach and both of those guys know
how to win a Super Bowl so that's a
great choice I'm gonna throw you another
curveball here I'm going to go with my
third choice Nick Foles I mean he's
that's not a currency I tried to say I
tried to sandbag you I was holding Nick
Foles for round three but go ahead you
got him so Nick Bowles beat the Patriots
in the Super Bowl he's done it it's the
only time he started and played against
the Patriots I think he owns the New
England Patriots yeah and and yeah I'll
tell you what look at what the Jaguars
had two years ago they were up by 10
points should have been 17 in the fourth
quarter but for an officiating error and
I think Nick Foles would have held a 10
point lead in the fourth quarter against
New England Patriots and that it is
gonna be a fascinating dynamic if they
cross paths in the postseason would Nick
falls in the Jaguars be able to handle
the Patriots I don't think the Patriots
want anything to do with Nick Falls
again although I guess they would they
would puff out their chest and say let's
have another shot at him I think based
upon what we saw the last time around
they should not want that alright I'm
gonna go with another one I guess is
fairly obvious and if we're gonna have
high hopes for the Cleveland Browns we
have to assume the Cleveland Browns are
a team that could stick it to the New
England Patriots with the talent that
they have with that Moxie that Baker
Mayfield brings to the table and if the
Browns end up being as good as people
expect them to be
they should be a threat to the Patriots
in the 2019 season in the postseason
more specifically and I guess it would
be fitting because the Browns the team
that Bill Belichick coached at one point
although that team is now the Ravens I
know
Browns fans and Ravens fans don't like
that when we pointed out but it's the
truth but still he coached in Cleveland
and it would be fitting to see the
Browns get a shot at the Patriots and I
think it's a team in the AFC that the
Patriots should be a little bit
concerned about at least for now the one
team we didn't mention is the Chargers
and I do think the Chargers are good
enough to contend and I think they will
content and even have a chance to knock
off the Chiefs and win that division but
I would say that's probably the only
team that we didn't mention there that
has a chance to do this I don't see any
of these Dark Horse's that we didn't
name coming out and getting it done we
did leave the Ravens off of the list and
the Ravens do have a history of going to
Foxborough and winning games in the
postseason I just think that whatever
they do on offense what what did this
revolutionary approach that they believe
they're gonna unleash on the NFL and
John Harbaugh made the recent comment to
NFL Network that it could be like the
49ers of the 1980s I think whatever it
is when they play if they cross paths in
the postseason I think Bill Belichick
will figure out how to stop Lamar
Jackson that's why I left the Ravens off
I just don't think this Ravens team and
I hate to give Joe Flacco more credit
than maybe people think he deserves but
I don't think this Ravens team is going
to be able to handle Bill Belichick and
the New England Patriots because by the
time they meet Belichick will have
everything he needs to figure out
exactly how to stop the Ravens offense
and as I'm saying that Sheree and listen
as I'm saying that I am consciously
aware of the fact that they're probably
gonna play it back on a Monday morning
in January after the Ravens beat the
Patriots in the playoffs
thanks to Lamar Jackson well I think we
both agree they have the defense they
have the defense almost every year and
that defense is going to keep them in
games it's can the offense get it done
and score enough points to win enough
games and that would include being the
Patriots to get where they want
go and I just think there's too many
question marks right now to put the
Ravens on that list and we have teams
that come out of nowhere and they could
be one of those teams because their
defense is so good but just too many
questions on offense right now for me to
say that they're contender to go into
Foxborough and knock off the Patriots
and get to the Super Bowl of course I
have a chance to engineer home-field
advantage for a postseason rematch with
the New England Patriots because they do
get together week nine in Baltimore on
NBC Sunday Night Football so halfway
through the season Bill Belichick will
get a crack at Lamar Jackson and company
and then he gets a second shot and look
what happened with the Chargers that
second pass through with that offense
last year the Chargers lost to the
Ravens the first time got together again
and knew how to stop that offense you
can't outsmart Bill Belichick and I know
that the Ravens have been trying to do
it for years
you can outmuscle him you can catch him
flat-footed like the Ravens have managed
to do but you're not gonna outsmart him
with this new offense he's gonna figure
it all out all right we're gonna take a
quick break when we return some things
that we'll be looking for tonight as the
preseason gets rolling first though
Shireen's picks as the things that pose
the biggest threat to the Patriots and
Tom Brady and injury to Tom Brady
she said it not me the cult's and Nick
falls in the Jaguars I've got the Chiefs
the Steelers and the Browns omitted from
the list the Chargers and the Ravens
they'll probably be salty about that but
hey it's only a three round draft we did
what we could go back more pets alive
right after this
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports